Alright guys, so we're just drop don't make me read chicken facts. I eat chicken oh
We're gonna eat fried chicken. I love fried chicken
How many days a week to eat fried Chicken like three four?
What what's there not to like about fried chicken?
Yeah, I agree. It like has like an endorphin release when I deep fried chicken like I feel happier
I had a lot experience of fried chicken I grew up with it um
My mom cooks it my grandma cooks it. I think her grandma cooked it
I like fried chicken. I mean I like chicken in general. That's why I'm in this video. It's one of the greatest long
Inventions of known to man thank you hmM
What is this? Why are people walking in we haven't met yet with uh?
They're so cute. Oh my God. You're such a fucking asshole. You're so cute
I have no words is this what fried chicken?
Becomes no, no, this is what becomes fried chicken feathers are gorgeous. You're very pretty animals like gold
We don't don't abandon this one all right. I'm gonna take the phone home goals and futures you Gonna
I would love to [and] you want to kiss each other little chicken kiss
I
Am honestly kind of bummed out that there's no chicken here
This changes nothing the woman you walked in with these I felt really bad
It might be affecting me it might be affecting them out there
I mean, we all have purposes in life and some of them wow I don't want to be sitting next to power my
it does make me want to learn more about where my chicken comes from
This would sleepy
You know it's in like the store
It's like not even an animal anymore, and like this is putting a face to it now. Are you getting an endorphin rush?
I'm good, though
Like thank you. Don't you know what no matter in what state chickens gonna be a little bit of a joy, you know?